identifica todos los rayos que se
muestran en la figura vamos a recordar
brevemente que era un rayo un rayo
consistía en empezar en algún cierto
punto digamos equis y avanzar en alguna
dirección indefinidamente
digamos hacia allá entonces el chiste es
que si llegamos y siguiéramos así hasta
el infinito vale y bueno para referirnos
a un rayo lo que hacíamos era tomar otro
punto sobre el rayo digamos un punto por
acá un punto y y escribir primero el
vértice luego ese otro punto y
finalmente arriba una flechita entonces
este de a caer el rayo xy y su vértice
era xy en realidad éste llegue nada más
sirve para determinar la dirección
pudimos haber tomado otro aquí y otro
acá y esos rayos serían exactamente el
mismo empezamos en xy vamos en esa
dirección bueno con estas ideas vamos a
empezar a identificar los rayos de esta
figura déjame empezar con jota como
vértice vale entonces qué rayos empiezan
en j bueno pues realmente el único
segmento que pasa por jota es el
segmento jh así que es el único que
tiene chance de ser rayo y en efecto sí
lo es bueno ir de jhc en rayo
podemos seguir indefinidamente después
de h vamos de jh nos pasamos y seguimos
indefinidamente hacia allá entonces jh
es uno de los rayos de la figura j h
muy bien ahora vayamos a h h pues a ver
h no puede ir hacia j porque h j se
termina en j
entonces como esta línea está cortada
aquí entonces h j no puede ser rayo y si
vamos hacia arriba pues hacia arriba no
tenemos ningún punto de referencia vaya
o sea esta figura que empieza aquí y va
hacia allá así es un rayo pero no
podemos referirnos a ella entonces está
acá o sea poner simplemente h podría ser
tentador pero como como esto no quiere
decir nada porque no tiene otro punto
que nos dé la dirección pues mejor no lo
ponemos vale entonces hasta ahorita el
único rayo que podemos denotar lo que
podemos escribir es el jota h bueno
ahora vayamos a los otros vamos a los
rayos que empiezan digamos en se deja de
cambiar de color vamos a poner verde
claro otra vez podría ser tentador
avanzar hacia allá pero no tenemos
ningún punto para hacer referencia
entonces aunque si es un rayo empezar
aquí e ir hacia allá no lo vamos a poner
porque porque no podemos referirnos a él
entonces nada más vamos a considerar los
que van al otro lado de se podemos ir
hacia él y de ahí podemos podemos
continuar indefinida
entonces ese sería un rayo
continuar indefinidamente y también
empezando desde podemos ir hacia efe
pero es lo mismo y gracias hacia a que
hacia efe nos da exactamente la misma
dirección entonces realmente el rayo se
y el rayo se efe con el mismo rayo
tienen el mismo vértice y van hacia la
misma dirección vale y aquí se sigue
indefinidamente bueno creo que eso
termina con el punto c ahora déjame
pasar al punto creo que hay varios que
pasan por ahí en el punto e tenemos tres
opciones podemos ir hacia c entonces
tenemos el rayo efe y en efecto y
gracias se nos permite continuar
indefinidamente podemos ir hacia a
tenemos él
y otra vez podemos continuar
indefinidamente porque aquí está la
flechita vale esto se sigue para allá y
también tenemos de a efe tenemos el rayo
efe
efe y quiero dejar muy claro que el rayo
efe y el cf son distintos aunque los dos
vayan hacia efe ahora sí son distintos
porque tienen un vértice distinto es
decir el punto inicial del rayo es
distinto vale bueno entonces tenemos
estos tres rayos con vértice gente
pasemos ahora digamos a efe vale
efe lo voy a hacer en color naranja
vamos a tomar este y acá que sucede ene
efe pues ene efe podemos ir hacia él
entonces tenemos que el rayo
efe efe y también podemos ir hacia ce
pero son el mismo rayo verdad otra vez
tenemos esta situación en la cual tienen
el mismo vértice inicial el mismo punto
inicial el mismo vértice pues iban en la
misma dirección y bueno si queremos ir
hacia la izquierda pues si hay un rayo
para allá pero no podemos describirlo
porque porque no hay un punto en el cual
podamos hacer referencia vale bueno
entonces estos son los únicos rayos que
podemos poner a espera me falta también
considerara a ver qué sucede contar en
el caso de a pues creo que con a no hay
ningún rayo o sea si intentamos ir hacia
aquí se corta la recta
no es un rayo porque no podemos seguir
indefinidamente y si intentamos ir hacia
allá pues no podemos referirnos a ese
rayo porque no hay ningún punto por acá
entonces realmente estos son los únicos
rayos que están definidos por puntos por
puntos que estén en la figura vale si
tuviéramos más puntos por ejemplo si
tuviéramos este de acá entonces
pudiéramos definir un montón de rayos
más si éste fuera g entonces podríamos
definir el g- gh
gf cj y todos los que llegan a g pero no
lo tenemos entonces pues ya pusimos
todos los que teníamos y también si
tuviéramos algunos aquí afuera pues
pudiéramos hacer referencia a esos que
no podíamos tendríamos el se hace acá
hacia allá h hacia allá y efe hacia allá
pero no los tenemos entonces pues o sea
leyendo esta pregunta lo que yo entiendo
es que nos piden identificar los rayos
que podamos nombrar es decir este rayos
que utilicen dos puntos de la figura y
esos son justo los que los que acabamos
de encontrar son estos seis de aquí si
son seis y uno
2 3 4 5 6 y entonces los rayos que
muestra la figura que usen puntos azules
son estos que escribimos y son los
únicos